one of the challenges we face in our
society is the access to scientific
tools is limited and so we've been
building and developing tools and
technologies to make the experience of
science more accessible and an example
of that happens to be a tool called fold
scope which we try to deploy so that
almost every single kid in the planet
will have a chance to experience the
microscopic wonders of biological
systems so full scope is an origami
microscope something that you put
together with your own hands it takes 5
10 minutes to put together and it allows
you to dive into the microscopic world
and essentially do microscopy almost
anywhere and one of the perspectives the
full scope is you should just compare it
as a pencil of microscopy just like you
carry around a pencil in your pocket you
would carry a microscope around in the
moment and inspiration or idea strikes
you should be able to just really dive
in and look at the microscopic scale and
I just got a whole bunch of spider eggs
it's really valuable to just have the
students document and my intuition is
those are
and there's also a whole bunch of algae
and all right we're ready to go back now
you have to describe tell us what you
see
do you see the fibers I do but do you
see the little carbon suit yeah the
black dot looks like little jaws yeah
yeah and then if you pay close attention
you will see these little holes and they
did oh so I can say this is actually
really really fun I can if you pay
attention into the mandible and again
your color will change the moment I
pointed to the tree you'll see a
different shade suddenly you move it to
the white light you see this different
contrast so move around and you will
notice in the pincers there are these
jaws that it's like a striations so hold
here and here and just point it out and
what you see you have to tell us what
you see and I think one thing you should
do is if you had a pencil or something
and sketch what you see that's the most
common thing I do for especially for
teaching kids it's that's the one thing
that they don't often do so it becomes
very important to share how they would
just draw and you don't want to be shy
from using more tape because this needs
to be mechanically strong because if
this is moving around then your image is
moving around and then for this purposes
let's also use the light module as well
because now we will sit down and
[Music]
what I'm doing is I'm just going
wherever I want to be right there so
there seems to be this green algae and
I'm
in there
we knew that people would do creative
things but the explosive nature of what
people did with it is really the most
heartwarming story for me many people
have said the most fun they have in
science is when they not only just
discover something but when they tell
somebody what they discovered to me
what's most important about this tool is
not just to the service of science but
science to the service of these people
what is the community gaining out of it
and that's what my goal is why is it
that we don't move towards a society
where people are actually engaged in
scientific discovery to a point where
they have some role to play directly in
it continue beyond this moment because
most of the time you know workshops
happen and people come together and so
there is an online community that we
created primarily for that and I'll just
show that site and one thing that I
would urge definitely for everybody is
you know I think we're all in some sense
have the opportunity to engage and you
all are enters too many kids and that's
the most valuable thing so that's this
is the ask give and take I mean this is
what I'm bringing to the table in which
you have to bring to the table with that
beyond this day that you think of this
community and I think there's lots of
fun things about this community that
this course will enrich your own
classrooms as well